I'm at the Eureka weather station in Nunavut,
in the Canadian High Arctic, about 80 degrees
north.
Here they provide weather reports not just
for the Arctic,
but for the transatlantic flights high above
it.
Because we're in Nunavut, there are three
official languages here:
English, French, and the local language: Inuktitut.
Although it’s difficult to be exact about
languages in the Arctic:
the line between dialects and languages gets
blurred,
people in different areas can understand some
of people say.
Like most languages here, Inuktitut is polysynthetic,
which means that something that needs a whole
sentence in English
can just be one long word,
with each part affecting all the others.
Now, in Greenland, similar languages are written
using the Latin alphabet,
but the words can seem unwieldy to English-speakers.
The Latin alphabet is a writing system that
evolved for a completely different language,
one with lots of short words and spaces.
But there is an alternative,
it's used all round northern Canada,
and to my eyes, it’s really cool.
A bit of history: the reason this writing
system exists is because
it was invented by Christian missionaries
who were trying to spread the gospel.
The first books printed in Inuktitut were
extracts from the Bible.
I’ve put some links in the description to
provide some context there, but:
there’s no way I can cover that in a short
video that’s mostly about linguistics.
First up: this is not an alphabet.
In an alphabet, vowels and consonants both
have letters,
which makes sense when you’ve speaking a
language
with a lot of complicated combinations of
sounds in it.
But Inuktitut, like a lot of polysynthetic
languages,
has a relatively simple syllable structure:
with rare exceptions,
the maximum you can have in a syllable is
a consonant, some vowels, and then another
consonant.
That is it, that is all your options.
A long, English one-syllable word like “scratched”
wouldn’t work here:
you need to put vowels in those consonant
clusters.
You need se-ce-ra-te-ched.
Long vowels being written with two letters,
that's also added to the long words,
so the Latin alphabet gets a bit overwhelmed.
But the Inuktitut script is not an alphabet.
It is an abugida.
Each symbol represents both a consonant and
a vowel.
The shape of the symbol tells you the consonant,
and here is the clever part:
the direction it's pointing tells you the
vowel.
And if it’s got a dot above it,
it’s a long vowel, like aa instead of a.
I’m not going to get the vowels exactly
right, I’m English.
And if there’s a little symbol, up afterwards,
you add another consonant at the end.
So my name, Tom, would be like this:
the curve shape means T,
it's pointing to the right, which means “u”,
the closest you can get to an o here,
and the right angle at the end means a closing
M.
Tum.
If your accent's different,
you might transcribe it a little differently,
you might flip the curve the other way.
Tam.
And if you're American,
you'd add a little dot there for a long vowel.
Taam.
So here is a simple word in Inuktitut: anaana.
Mother.
Like almost every language in the world,
the word for mom is a sound that a baby will
make accidentally.
Sorry parents, it was probably an accident.
A triangle means no consonant,
and pointed left always means a simple “a”.
Next, that shape means “n”, pointing left
means “a”,
and the dot means long.
“naa”.
Then the same again, without the dot. “na”.
Annana.
The word for father is ataata.
Swap those spools out for the curve,
the T from Tom, and there you go.
Ataata.
And yes, of course it’s more complicated
than this,
I’m literally speaking baby talk,
but compare this to the Latin alphabet
where there's just arbitrary symbols that
you have to learn.
There’s design here.
There's intent.
There isn't complicated letters with unwritten
rules that all influence each other.
This is an easy script to learn,
and for an endangered language with only about
30,000 fluent speakers?
That is a really good attribute to have.
I'm here thanks to Chris Hadfield's Generator
Arctic, and so are these two!
-- I'm Norm from Tested.
-- And I'm Joey from Tested.
-- And we're here shooting a bunch of educational
videos as well.
You can find those at youtube.com/testedcom
Links are in the description or on screen
now!